my name is uri i come from a company
called sky
i'll give you kind of the formal spiel
so sky is the only full go-to-market
engine that enables smarter decisions
and better outcomes
our platform includes a suite of
data-driven products
for market intelligence omni-channel
media activation
testing and measurement
within that kind of broader context i'm
a data science team lead
and
i'm going to discuss a little bit how we
tackled an issue that we're calling
conversion latency
uh before we dive into the problem just
to kind of introduce the team
so uh
like i said i'm a data science team lead
a team of four and on this project uh
three team members worked on it
yonatan is even here
we're part of a wider
optimization and insights group that's
being managed gracefully by by amit
euless who's also
joined us
within the responsibilities of the team
so we
were responsible for most of the
optimization
tools in sky
that covers
um
most of the digital marketing management
in sky in terms of optimization so we're
talking bids
budgets um forecasting
um long-term kind of
planning for digital marketing
all our products are in production
they meet a lot of clients a lot of
money is passing through our tools
and just to kind of give a little
background on performance marketing and
uh
basically how we measure
uh
the quality or the efficiency of the
campaign in in
the pay-per-click setting so an
advertiser pays for the clicks he gets
on his ad pays the publisher in our
scenario we're talking about amazon as
the publisher
and in order to measure the efficiency
of the campaign we're looking at
the ratio between the revenue
that the advertiser gets on his
purchases
divided by the cost of the advertising
itself like i said the cost goes
is counted based on the clicks
so this ratio
return on ad spend row us roi
we kind of use those terms
interchangeably
in order to measure this this row us
this ratio we basically need to identify
the sale or the conversion
uh when when we call it a conversion
that the meaning is when a click turns
into an actual purchase so
the name is conversion um so we need to
identify these conversions match them
to the relevant click and that way we
can calculate
the campaign efficiency
so
why is there even an issue here well
this is kind of a classical example
a potential buyer he searches on he or
she searches on amazon
they click on an ad
but they don't make the purchase
immediately
because it's sunday i don't know
beginning of the week they need time to
to sync to to browse to compare to other
products
and only on friday they actually make
the purchase
but at the point of the purchase
we're actually updating
the conversion count
for sunday
so
you can think of this process as kind of
a travel back in time
so
in that way we can actually say okay the
efficiency of the campaign is is based
on on these data points
and and and get the notion of how
efficient the campaign is
but during this time frame where the
buyer is
deliberating comparing
the advertiser still needs to make
decisions on his ad campaign
sorry
click
click on an ad
so i see an ad in amazon
and i click on it
and that is registered and at that point
the advertiser is paying amazon money
for that click
and
so we need to kind of keep count of the
clicks
and we need to keep count of the
conversions in order to be able to to
say how efficient the campaign is
does that cover the the question
what after you keep on that
sorry what doctor do you keep on
well a lot of data a lot of metadata it
kind of depends on
how the click is uh registered so uh
in this in in this scenario in amazon
we're kind of dependent on the the
information that amazon shares on the
click
but there are instances for instance in
in search or in facebook
which we also deal with where we
basically own the cookie and the
metadata that comes with it so it kind
of depends on the channel um
but
the point i wanted to make is that
during this kind of deliberation time
the advertiser needs to make changes to
his advertising activity he needs to
decide if he wants to stop it activate
more increase budgets reduce bids
but he doesn't have a good notion of how
efficient his his campaign is and he
needs but and how to make the decision
of where to invest
his money his advertising money
so again i'm reiterating the point of
making decisions based on partial data
and this this time frame where the the
buyer is is thinking about buying is
what we call the conversion latency
now for for technical reasons of how
uh
the conversion is attributed to the
click there is a kind of window of 14
days what we call we used to call the
cookie window but essentially the click
window you can you know the attribution
window
and during these 14 days we want to make
a prediction on what the final value of
conversions and revenue will be
for that given historical date or
historical clicks
as i just mentioned the goal is to
predict the final attributed revenue and
conversion count while buyers are still
browsing
uh and
we do too we want to do two things with
that one is show it to the user the
advertiser so we can make better
decisions but also we as we manage
optimization tools we want to feed that
information into optimization and make
better decisions uh as fast as we can
okay so if we if we come to formulate
this problem so naturally it feels like
a time series issue or time series
problem
or time series prediction problem
but
it's not a typical one
for for several reasons one for the most
part this process is an accumulation
process
so we start with a low number of
conversions on sunday and as time
progresses the numbers rise
it's mostly an accumulation process
because amazon does have a return
mechanism where you can return
purchases you've made and data
corrections etc
another thing that kind of is kind of
different from a
time series prediction typically is it's
it's a short time series so the maximum
length is what we call the attribution
window the 14 days but
we also want to make predictions two
days after the click so the time series
for prediction is just two times time
steps long again not a typical time
series issue
of course since
like i mentioned it's an accumulation
process so there's no kind of
autocorrelation or seasonality within
the
observation of the time series
um and again
we want to make a prediction uh
one or two days after the click already
so
uh
on a single prediction day the model
needs to predict for yesterday day
before yesterday and so on 14 days back
so essentially we get a multi-horizon
prediction issue or problem so the model
needs to handle predictions
where the
observation that it's a predicting on
can be anywhere from one to 13 time
steps
long okay so
we formulated the problem
this is kind of how we
try to solve it
first of all where do we get the data
um
since we have a data table that is
synchronized with amazon every day
sometimes even several times a day
like i said we want to go back in time
and see what was the value in the table
13 days ago and 12 days ago etc so
snowflake which is our data lake uh
software i guess or solution
has a feature that's
neatly called time travel where you can
query the table and ask what was the
values in the table
for specific time step
so when we come to build our training
data for the model
we essentially want to collect
many of these examples of the snapshot
of time series of snapshots so
the query although it becomes quite ugly
it does the trick and it allows us to to
collect these
these time series uh of updates
for the historical prediction historical
performance date
so
i mentioned the time series component
and this is kind of a schematic view of
the model architecture that we we were
using here and i started with with the
time series component so
uh
essentially it's eventually fed into a
recurrent
neural network stack
for for example an stm in our case
but before we actually fit it in into a
recurrent stack we need to
simulate the situation in in production
in serving while training so we do that
by actually taking the full time series
and masking it
so
yeah i see people are nodding so it
makes sense
we take each observation we have in the
training set
we choose three random masks and we mask
them and and in that way we get the
training data
for the model
what are the information yeah are
collecting so
there is quite a lot of information that
is collected through clicks
but
okay so essentially we're looking at
aggregated daily data we're not
interested in a single click
or what happens for a single buyer
we're trying to look at if we take all
the clicks of a certain day in
aggregation and the partial conversions
that we already have for that day and we
try to predict the final conversions for
that day for that campaign
sorry
is it sorry
no it's it's the it's the values i have
now for that for that day
but it's an aggregation over the entire
day so i'm not looking at single event
data i'm looking at an aggregation a
daily aggregation
we're also switching
to hourly not in this project but hourly
data is also obviously interesting in
this in this context so
but but currently we're talking daily
data
well i have a feeling that if if we
switch to hourly the granularity itself
will provide more information in terms
of how the time series behaves uh with
with the update so
now all i see is a single update per day
while if i see several updates
per day that's more information and
hopefully that will give better
predictions but it's not something we we
tested out yet but it it feels the right
direction
we talked about the time series
component and
the output of is concatenated with two
more components
the first of which is what we call the
campaign name
embedding or a campaign name model
it's based on the fastex library we're
training a custom model
on on our data and
just to kind of give a taste of what the
data looks like so these are
typical examples of what a campaign name
might be
it's
built of characters but i wouldn't call
it like a language one can read and
really understand too much from
there are of course
general abbreviations maybe product and
brand names are part of the of the text
but there are also a lot of client
specific naming conventions uh
abbreviations that they use internally
and are not necessarily
cross-cross-client
and
of course we also have a
a
marketing activity across all amazon
marketplaces and regions so it's also
multilingual so these are just examples
in english but we have
as many languages as amazon has regions
or marketplaces
so
kind of these examples and these these
properties of the campaign name led us
to to to the feeling that we need to
train a custom model
because
it's not something that a model trained
on on wikipedia or on twitter would
really be that helpful
um another thing that fasttex was kind
of a
nice to have in that sense is
the fact that the representation in fast
text is is character-based
uh or character engrams uh so each
character
seen in the training data is part of the
vocabulary as well as n-grams so
combinations or typical combinations of
characters in the data so the
abbreviations and stuff like that we we
we expect fast text in this context to
catch them
also the fact that it's character-based
so we get the multilingual out of the
books
uh so that also covers this issue and
again the fact that it's character based
gives the inductiveness so we can create
a representing representation vector
representations for campaigns that we're
not seeing during training so that kind
of widens the scope so we can also give
predictions for new campaigns that were
just newly created etc etc
another nice thing that fastex kind of
gives us
is the ability to train is supervised
and give it an objective for training
and not just based on the context of the
tokens or uh
or
or anything of that sort but
in this sense what the task we gave it
was to predict what we call revenue per
conversion at the campaign level so it's
basically the price of the product being
sold by that campaign
so
we're inserting into or
or providing
the the dense representation some notion
of what the campaign is selling or at
least
how uh
how expensive the product is
we have a feeling that
people
take more time when they buy when the
price of the product they're buying is
higher
so we expect that to have an impact on
on the latency and on the latency
prediction
when looking at the
at the embedding space once we've done
the embedding on the campaigns
one nice property that
is kind of easy to see is is the
separation between the price bins
uh
so
this is the
the embedding space
projected to 3d
uh the the vectors we're building are 10
dimensional
uh
and we're covering about 360 000
campaigns that actually have conversions
and it's it's
easy to see that there's a nice
separation between uh which campaign
lies in which uh price bin
uh
so that kind of gives us confidence in
in the the information we we want is in
the embedding space
and another thing that's also
hard to see here maybe on on the screen
is that when you look at
campaigns that are near each other in
the original embedding space they share
a lot of characters
as one would expect from a from a from a
language model so
we have a
in a joint sense both the proximity
based on the the actual text of the
campaign the campaign text of the
campaign name and the price of the
product being sold
in the company
okay
the final component we used in the model
is what we're calling campaign structure
embedding and it's also graph based but
not a graph convolutional network like
was mentioned in the first talk kind of
a simpler a graph model but
first maybe
i'll say a few words on
why we even have a graph
so
advertisers
if you look at their activity you can
think of it as a hierarchy so we have
the the advertiser at the top
advertiser has several profiles and
usually these profiles
are matching
an account in amazon
and that usually means that they have a
separate currency in a separate time
zone
and you can see kind of three examples
from three different advertisers and how
they manage the campaigns uh
the the left the bottom left is kind of
is not a typical example where an
advertiser put all these campaigns in
one profile but usually you'll see
these kind of things where each
advertiser has several profiles and each
profile has a many campaigns
um
in in this representation i colored the
campaigns based on the marketplace the
amazon region but in the graph
representation they're actually separate
nodes so
different advertisers are
connected in the graph representation
through the marketplace nodes
so
we expect similarity between campaigns
from different advertisers to an extent
if they share the same marketplace
so again the idea is to have all this
information in the embedding space
so since we have different node types
this is considered a heterogeneous graph
and it kind of limits or not limits but
it helps you choose which
which
embedding model
you're going to to work with
um and we chose to use this mode
because it supports
multi-relations in our context you can
think of
edges between different types of nodes
as different types of edges and then it
can you can consider it a multi-relation
what this mod does is it's basically an
encoder decoder approach and it
represents
um
the relation between
the the node
the edge or the relation and uh the the
other node and each of these are are a
learned representation so they are
learned during during training
and the decoder is defined as as a
as a dot product between the three of
them so
they kind of
defined a three-way dot product
the loss function
is is called margin loss or hinge loss
the idea is that it encourages a
triplets that really exist in the graph
to get a low score and a part of the
process is what's called negative
sampling where we take existing triplets
existing
a
source relation target nodes
and corrupt them so
for instance we change the origin node
we change the relation type we change
the target node and
the loss function since that triplet
does not exist in the graph penalizes it
and that
is what you know uh because it causes
the model to to a
uh
it connects
converge sorry thank you
and give us kind of an embedding that
maintains this the structure that we
want
again when we look at the the embedding
space
um
we can see and this is colored by the
amazon region we can see that the
campaigns are grouped relatively nicely
according to the region
and
and the regions themselves are
relatively separated and homogeneous
so again it kind of gives us confidence
that this information is well embedded
in in the embedding space
um and if if i took if i take one of the
previous advertiser examples i showed
and i look at it's it's specific
embedding for those campaigns again we
can see
uh that uh in the embedding space
specific profiles are clustered together
there's nice separation between the
profiles so again where
this structure information is is
well embedded in space and existing in
the in the vector representation
so these are some of the results this is
basically a prediction versus actual for
revenue
it's colored according to the length of
the time series
um this is from production
and so this is already midi clients
being used both in the ui and in in in
our optimization tools
just to kind of give a sense of kind of
the training architecture and the moving
part so
as i mentioned the source of the data is
from snowflake but we're working in the
cloud and all the training and and
serving of the models is done through
it's done on top of a sagemaker so
we need to move the data to s3
pro do the training etc
report the metrics to ml flow
and uh back to to s3 and the artifacts
are used as models in sagemaker for
serving
um
all of this orchestration is done
via airflow
that's kind of the
the the training uh
structure or architecture of how things
work here
um
and to give kind of a taste of the scale
of things we're doing so we're
currently we're covering around 170
advertisers on sky
about 185 000 campaigns every day get
predictions for the last 14 days
the training is done around
a little less than three million
observations for as the training set and
in terms of the revenue we're actually
predicting it's well above 20 million
dollars every day
uh of
revenue values that clients get as a
prediction
for their activity
any questions or anything
what was the reason
for
uh
well we're limited by by the tracking of
the conversion so
amazon that matching where the
conversion is matched to sunday
it can only happen in a time frame of 14
days not longer
than that so we're limited to 14 days
that's the default configuration there
are there are there are excuses
clients that configure it to be a longer
period but
the default is 14 and that's that's most
of the cases are 40.
how much computing power does it take
you to do all this computation
well it's it's trained asynchronously so
there's no real-time issue here we're
training the model once a week
the training time i think currently is
around 12 hours how many calls
it's not a gpu or anything
it's it's it's a sage maker machine
machine i think it is 16 or maybe more
yeah yeah it's on stage i i i wouldn't
train this locally how much yeah thank
you yeah yeah sure it's a price issue
adventure
uh i wonder how you take into account uh
special dates etc that might interfere
with uh
representing uh
time
so special events and and that's kind of
a general issue for us in sky in any
digital marketing
if you look at the amazon
prime days
or
i don't know black friday stuff about
holidays and sundays
well sunday versus weekly is not is not
such a big issue but things like
christmas prime day
black fridays cyber mondays
we were surprised for instance by
president day recently which kind of
really
threw the model off
so we're currently kind of semi-manually
monitoring the data that's fed into the
model both in the training and the
serving side about
whether seasonality like
some products in some season are more
likely to
well that's long term seasonality i i
agree but it's very long term like in
seasonality over the year and the time
frames we're dealing with here are very
very short so
i don't feel that we're really affected
by long-term seasonality weekly
seasonality might be a bit of an issue
uh i i didn't mention it but it the day
of week is also part of one of the
features of the model um but we haven't
seen that it has that much of an impact
our model is robust
sorry robust in what sense like let's
say you take the
last the model you had a week ago until
today how much so we
we haven't done that sort of an analysis
on the model like a drift or stuff like
that we're still
as i mentioned
semi-manually monitoring the data to see
that it makes sense and
we we have an example of president's day
that that did cause problems for us
um but we're transitioning into a more
automated way of looking at the data
it's a bit complex because
we didn't find any tool that can give us
like real automated statistics on the
data when when we consider it as a time
series or even a matrix uh
it's not we didn't find anything really
out of the box maybe maybe we're missing
so last question there
do you have a baby
like let's say 50 of the traffic will be
with the new building 50 percent at some
baseline
okay so before we went with this
architecture to production we went to
production with a baseline model that
was based on simple averages at the
campaign level and before deploying this
we obviously compared it to the baseline
and
luckily we beat it pretty well so it was
it was an easy decision to go with this
but
the rollout to the client's ui has been
ga so all clients see see the values we
predict in the ui
but for the optimization tools were a
bit
more careful so we're releasing it a bit
slower than you know full ga immediately
uh and we're monitoring the impact so
when we take a client's portion of
activity and activate the latency
correction on it we we do we're
currently doing mostly a before and
after analysis and it's not that easy
because clients also make changes to the
activity
um
but
choosing
two groups of activity that are similar
enough in order to do an a b test is not
that simple i
we're well versed with a b test in
general because it's very typical in in
digital marketing to do an a b test as
an advertiser before you launch a a
marketing activity so
we're very familiar with
a b testing methodology and and we've
done many a b tests it's very difficult
to find
similar enough activity uh and to
actually do a real really good a b test
so
it's not it's not always helpful uh
though some clients insist in in other
scenarios to do
thank
inaudib
[Applause]